grab some carrots what i said grab some
carrots
what said he's an irishman and the negro
is
his war that is definitely not what i
said because we have the fourth season
of fargo and there is so much to talk
about
in this video we'll be going over the
ending of fargo season 4
as well as taking a deep dive into its
meaning that crazy post-credit reveal
and much much more so sit on down with a
nice slice of pie
and make sure to like and subscribe
because here we
go the final episode is called storia
americana or
translated from italian american history
and it's no wonder it's called that
since both the very first and last
episode
start and end with ethel rita smutny's
history report of the strange events
which occurred in kansas city missouri
from 1950 to 1951 my name is etherita
pearl smutney
this is my history report she questions
who writes these history books who
chooses what to remember and what to
leave out
much of american history has been
written by old white men so it's only
fitting this story is told from the lens
of a young black woman
the final episode begins with a
cavalcade of characters who have died
throughout the season truly showing just
how bloody it's been
donatellofada paolo antoon calamita
omi defy otis doctor senator swaney
gaetano and rabbi milligan
that's not even covering the characters
that will die in this episode but we'll
get to that by the park here we have loy
cannon head of canon limited an
african-american crime syndicate
operating out of kansas city
alongside abel violante a man whose last
name
literally means violent loy is here to
strike a deal with the fatah crime
family after war broke out between his
operation
and the italians you might notice how
it's summertime here while most of the
season and
past seasons of fargo have taken place
during the winter that's because
production was halted during much of
covet 19 and episodes 10 and 11
hadn't been shot yet and were put on
hold until proper safety measures were
put in place
last episode ethel rita came to loy and
gave him something along with a proposal
that would sway the gang war in loy's
favor
she came with a ring and not just any
ring this is the ring that belonged to
donatello fada the former head of the
fatah crime family who was killed by
nurse orienta mayflower way back in
episode 1.
she likes to collect mementos of her
victims and when ethel rita was cleaning
her home she stumbled upon her closet
filled with various poisons obituary
clippings and
other knickknacks loy will use the ring
deposit that josto hired orienta the
nurse whom he was having an affair with
to kill his
father so he could take over the family
meanwhile josto isn't doing so well
drinking himself silly over the death of
his brother who died last episode
gaetano it's kind of ironic considering
for most of the season josto was trying
to kill him you'll notice josto is
framed against
an 1880 painting called the storm by
french artist pierre caught
it features a man and a woman seeking
refuge from a storm and
i can't help but find this imagery
similar to him in orienta near the end
of the episode
storms also feature heavily throughout
the season a metaphor for being unable
to control things
you wish to think that you can control
things that's why god created tornadoes
to remind us just like the tornado that
sucks up calamita and rabbi milligan in
episode
9. the season like ones before it
feature moments that are
so absurd it can only be described as a
twist of fate
like when gitano trips and accidentally
shoots himself or when a kid's
peashooter ends up putting the head of
the fada family in hospital orietta who
i found to be the most interesting
character of the season
has found herself in prison having been
arrested for the attempted murder of dr
harvard
after she poisoned one of his macaroons
she'll later be released on bail and
taken to the fadas but
more on that in a bit the mule loy's son
hands over the keys to the smutney's
house loy had taken over the house which
also operates as a mortuary business
after the family took a loan from him
that they couldn't pay back but with
ethel rita's delivery of the ring to loy
it seems all their debts are forgiven
and now things can finally go back to
normal
josto however is still filled with rage
and decides to take matters into his own
hands and assassinate those who have
wronged him this includes dr harvard who
didn't allow his father to be treated at
his hospital because he was italian
and the mayor you might recall josto was
engaged the mayor's daughter as part of
a business deal
a deal that was canceled after the
mayor's connection to josto and the gang
war became
too heated josto is informed that loy
has been killed but
that's a lie he's confronted by abel who
has brought along orienta
they believe josto hired orienta to kill
his father and
orienta says it's true he told her to
quote take care of him but she took that
to mean you know
kill him you kill your father
so you can wear the crown then you kill
your brother
so you don't have to share across the
city loy's men end up killing lionel
halloway who last episode was going to
double-cross loy to take control of the
cannon business in kansas city
for now it seems like everything is
going well for loy he's made peace with
the italians and taking care of his
rival
lionel but there's one person he hasn't
made peace with
and that's going to end up costing him
josto and oriera
are taken to a secluded field to be
killed and it's kind of fitting that
orienta's last request is to be shot
second so she can watch josta be killed
she has a kink for death and relishes
watching josto die even though her end
is mere moments away
i love this shot from episode 7 which
frames orienta as an
angel of death it's also worth noting
this shot of orienta's disfigured
reflection
even though she puts on lipstick before
her death it won't hide how
ugly her soul is and how many of you
discovered the faint image of the ghost
that haunted the smutnies beside her
here in episode 10 we learned this
person was called theodore roach the
captain of a slave ship that brought
ethel rita's great-grandfather over from
africa
he's a man with a wooden nose eyes sewn
shut who etherida's mother calls the
devil himself he was killed by ethel
rita's great grandfather and now he
haunts the family to this day
but this image of him next to oriera
seems to hint that he's latched on to
something new
something with great evil orienta
herself so i like to think the smutnies
are no longer haunted by this ghostly
entity
you may also have noticed the person who
ends up killing josto and orienta as a
young joe bullo who featured prominently
in season 2 played by brad garrett he'll
later go on to be the front man for the
northern expansion of the kansas city
crime syndicate with everything
seemingly right in the world loy comes
home to find his front door ajar
fearing it could be someone trying to
harm him or his family he goes in alone
to find a bowl of cereal his missing son
satchel's favorite food and has read a
baseball cap satchel has come home and
the two are reunited
in episode 6 rabbi milligan save satchel
from being killed and the two go
on the run unlike himself he wants
satchel to have a choice what happens to
him in his life he wants him to be able
to choose between going back to his
family
one filled with crime and being on his
own
i never got to choose a child soldier
that's what they made me
but that's not gonna happen to you abel
and loy agree that all is forgiven
between the two warring parties but the
italians have made a new deal
half of all loy's businesses will belong
to them and loy is in no position to
argue
the italians are a giant multi-city
crime syndicate with enough power to
crush
lloyd's small operation even if abel
were killed another would just take his
place
loy arrives home after his meeting
proclaiming that the war is over he
looks at his family through the window
and smiles
even though he's lost most of his
business he has his family back which is
the most important you might even have
caught satchel reading how to win
friends and influence people the same
book which hunk swindell talked about in
episode 9.
how to win friends and influence people
six ways to make people like you
number one become genuinely interested
in other people the tragedy here is just
when loy has everything right he's
viciously stabbed by zelmar the woman he
turned into the police which resulted in
her lover swanny being killed
it's satchel who ends up discovering his
father as he dies right in front of him
you may have also noticed the oranges
scattered about oranges were what loy's
men used to smuggle guns from across the
country
and orange is also the hue of the
executioner in the painting
summary execution under the moorish
kings of granada which features
prominently both in episode 10
and the final shot of the season the
executioner has been killed and having
ethel rita framed behind this picture
suggests this might not be the last time
we see her character
speaking of that final shot we see ethel
rita reciting her history report as she
leaves carrying two suitcases
i like to believe this is her going off
to college but it's open to
interpretation and i hope you stayed for
the post credit sequence with the big
reveal that satchel is season two's mike
milligan
all grown up basically the entire season
has been a backstory for this character
informing us how mike came to be we see
he took the last name milligan after the
man who saved his life and if you
remember from season 2
mike's character was very charismatic
and talkative quite different from the
satchel we saw in the show
however we do see this change when he
starts reading how to win friends and
influence people he's on his journey to
becoming mike witnessing his father's
death and knowing what his father did
undoubtedly guided his decision to
become an enforcer for the kansas city
mob it's ironic that even though rabbi
milligan gave him the choice to do
whatever he wants with his life he still
chose to go back to his family and
live this life of crime and it really
begs the question are our choices our
own
or are we bound to twisted acts of fate
which the show so
devilishly likes to show us the show
also deals with the idea of power almost
every character in this season strives
for it josto is arguably the most
powerful yet likes to be powerless in
his sexual encounters with orienta
loy believes having more power will keep
his family safe but it ends up doing the
exact
opposite he'd even trade his own son for
more i traded my
own son to my enemy for power otis
becomes a cop believing its power will
save him but he ends up having to make
deals with criminals in order to feel
safe
all i know is i feel better when i'm in
charge when i got the power
orienta loves the power of being able to
take a life
since as a child she had no power over
her own growing up powerless in the
hospital her mother having to exchange
sexual favors with doctors just in order
for her to get the right care
but power in fargo season 4 is
inextricably linked to race
the italians irish and canon families
for example turn to crime because at
every turn they are shunned by the
already established quote-unquote
white people they can't climb the social
or economic ladder because they are not
deemed equal and here's what you need to
know about the people in that room
none of them were white all fighting for
the rights have been created equal
orienta dr harvard and deffy are prime
examples of white people whose privilege
gives them
authority and power over others what
does it feel like to be so sure you're
right and know that nobody cares
as showrunner noah holly told the
hollywood reporter this story of satchel
is the story of america
a black man raised by an irish american
who himself was raised by a jewish
family and then an italian family
no wonder the last episode is called
american history
thanks for watching everyone if you
liked the video be sure to give it a
like and subscribe
and share and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much